.
>> Brian: AND HE COULD NOT PLAY
HOME GAMES OR AWAY GAMES, ONLY
26 GAMES.
"FOX & FRIENDS" WEEKEND CO-HOST
WITH A RICH SPORTS BACKGROUND,
WILL CAIN JOINS US NOW.
HE'S NOT EXAGGERATING, IF HE HAD
A GOOD SEASON, HE WOULD GET A
FOUR-YEAR, 100 MILLION CONTRACT
FROM SOMEBODY.
>> FROM SOMEBODY, HE SAYS IT
SCARED OTHER TEAMS FROM TRADING
FOR HIM, OPTIONS BUT NOT MANY.
WHY, BECAUSE THE STIGMA CREATED,
THE NARRATIVE, THE STORY ABOUT
KYRIE IRVING, OH, HE'S A BAD
TEAMMATE, UNWILLING TO DO WHAT
IT TAKES TO BE AVAILABLE FOR HIS
TEAM AND THE TRUTH IS BRIAN,
LIKE SORT OF THE MOST BENIGN
THING SAID ABOUT PEOPLE, NOT
JUST NBA STARS BUT PEOPLE THAT
CHOSE NOT TO BE VACCINATED.
YOU ARE A TERRIBLE PERSON IN
SOCIETY, YOU ARE HURTING OTHERS,
YOU ARE KILLING YOUR NEIGHBOR.
THIS IS ALL THAT WAS SAID FOR
ANYONE THAT CHOSE NOT TO GET --
REMAIN UNVACCINATED.
ONLY REASON FOR THE MANDATE, THE
ONLY REASON HE COULD NOT PLAY,
THAT TEACHERS AND MILITARY
PERSONNEL WERE -- LOST THEIR
JOB, HOSPITAL WORKERS LOST THEIR
JOB WAS BECAUSE THE VACCINE WAS
SUPPOSED TO STOP TRANSMISSION.
AND WE KNOW THAT IS FALSE.
ANTHONY FAUCI TESTED POSITIVE
AFTER FOUR SHOTS.
THE PFIZER CEO TESTED POSITIVE
THE SECOND TIME IN TWO MONTHS
DESPITE FOUR SHOTS OF COVID.
IT DOES NOT STOP TRANSMISSION
AND WE USE PEOPLE LIKE KYRIE,
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY, AVERAGE
AMERICANS AS SCAPEGOATS AND
YANKED THEIR JOBS, THEIR MONEY,
AND YANKED THEIR REPUTATION AWAY
FROM THEM.
>> Brian: THE MILITARY IS GUTTED
BECAUSE OF IT, COPS HAVE BEEN
FIRED BECAUSE OF IT, NURSES HAVE
BEEN TOLD TO GET OUT BECAUSE OF
IT, SLOAN KETTERING AND OTHERS,
AND IN DIFFERENT CITIES, SO WHEN
WE BRING UP KYRIE IRVING, WE ARE
BRINGING UP AN EXAMPLE OF A GUY
WHO HAD A JOB THAT JUST SAID I
WON'T GET IT.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO TELL ME
WHAT TO DO WITH MY BODY, I'M IN
GREAT SHAPE, HE'S RIGHT, ALMOST
DESTROYED A HUGE TEAM THAT MIGHT
NEVER BE THE SAME.
BECAUSE OF HIM, KEVIN DURANT
SAID I CAN'T DO IT ALONE.
WHEN HE DID PLAY ON AWAY GAMES
IT WAS OK.
BUT THE END, HE WANTED TO BE
TRADED.
HE COULD HAVE BLEW UP A
FRANCHISE, THE VALUE BIG TIME
BUT THEY ARE ALL BACK.
>> YEAH, AND PEOPLE PUT THAT ON
KYRIE.
EVERYTHING YOU JUST DESCRIBED,
JUST GET THE SHOT, MAN, JUST GET
THE SHOT.
HOW INTRUSIVE, HOW TOTALLY
IGNORANT OF PRIVACY IS THAT TYPE
OF RESPONSE THAT HEY, MAN, JUST
MAKE THE MEDICAL DECISION FOR
EVERYBODY ELSE, EVEN THOUGH IT
DOES NOT DO ANYTHING FOR
EVERYBODY ELSE.
AND I LIKE YOU SAY THIS.
IT IS A LOT TO GIVE UP
$100 MILLION, HE HAS AND WILL
MAKE MILLIONS AND MILLIONS MORE,
AND HOW MANY OF US WOULD GO 100
MILLION, SHOT OR NO SHOT.
SO YOU HAVE TO GIVE KYRIE CREDIT
FOR HIS PRINCIPLE.
BUT AVERAGE AMERICANS GAVE UP
100% OF THEIR INCOME, GAVE UP
THEIR JOB ON PRINCIPLE AND WE AS
SOCIETY, NOT YOU, NOT ME, BUT
SOCIETY, WE TOLERATED THIS
REALLY, THIS UGLY INSTINCT TO
SCAPEGOAT OTHERS.
>> Brian: RIGHT, THE VARIANTS
ROLLED OUT AND THE VACCINE WAS
NOT EFFECTIVE AND THE PRESIDENT
SAYS OH, BY THE WAY, PANDEMIC
OVER, AS SLIP SHOT AS HE SAID
YOU BETTER GET THE VACCINE OR A
PANDEMIC OF